[Musik]
hallo meine lieben heute zeige ich euch
ein super einfaches und dennoch sehr
sehr leckeres rezept für vanille
hörnchen
damals habe ich mir die pudding hörnchen
oder vanille hörnchen je nachdem wie man
sie nennen mag immer ganz gern beim
bäcker gekauft aber seit ich weiß wie
einfach das geht mache ich sie lieber zu
hause selber
nun zeige ich euch aber die zutaten für
unseren süßem hefeteig wir benötigen
mail lauwarme milch neutrales öl da habe
ich rapsöl genommen außerdem puderzucker
backpulver und trockenhefe oder frische
hefe die genauen mengenangaben schreibe
ich euch wie immer unten de infobox
zuallererst werden die trockenen zutaten
vorbereitet und hierfür müssen wir sie
einfach nur mission dh wir geben zu
unserem mehr noch das backpulver und die
trockenhefe und verrühren das gut
miteinander
[Musik]
anschließend geben wir die milch das öl
und dem puderzucker in unserer schüssel
verrühren das gut der puderzucker löst
sich ein bisschen besser auf ich mag das
noch mal ganz gerne und habe das gefühl
dass der teig dann viel flüssiger wird
wie könnte aber auch schon dessen
normalen zucker verwenden
anschließend geben wir die trockenen
zutaten mit dazu und verkneten dass
alles gut zu einem teig kneten den teig
am liebsten mit den händen ihr könnt
natürlich auch eure küchenmaschine
verwenden ist aber wirklich gar nicht
nötig denn innerhalb von fünf minuten
ist euer teig fertig ich kenne ihn dann
am liebsten noch auf der arbeitsfläche
schön glatt geht ihnen dann zurück in
die schüssel aber auch nur so lange bis
die füllung zubereitet haben denn der
teig der muss nicht extra aufgeben ich
bestreichen hier noch mit etwas öl damit
er auch die austrocknet gebe ein
geschirrtuch drüber und zeigt euch dann
die zutaten für den vanillepudding
hierfür benötigen wir milch speisestärke
zucker 1 eigelb und vanille extrakt wer
keine vanille extrakte hat kann auch das
mag einer schulter nehmen oder zur not
auch vanillezucker zuallererst werden
speisestärke zucker und ein wenig milch
in der schüssel verrührt gibt da nicht
all zu viel milch ein ca 10 esslöffel
das sollte reichen und dann rühren das
schön glatt bis wir das eigelb mit dazu
tun sobald die mischung dann klingen
frei verrührt wurde geben das eigelb mit
dazu und hören dass auch noch mal gut
unter dieser schritt wäre somit erledigt
und wir gehen rüber an den herd wo wir
den rest dem ich einmal aufkochen
an der stelle geben wir auch noch unser
vanille extrakt mit dazu ihr könntet ihr
jetzt auch das mag der vanille eingeben
und auch die schote damit wir das volle
aroma erhalten
anschließend lassen wir das unter rühren
aufkochen und dann geht es auch schon
weiter mit unserer speisestärke mischung
von vorhin
[Musik]
so die milch kocht gerade auf und an der
stelle geben wird zügig unsere mischung
von vorhin mit hinein mit der
speisestärke dem zucker und dem eigelb
und rühren dass mit dem schneebesen
richtig schön unter lassen das doch
einmal aufkochen damit es ein legt und
dann ist umso vanillepudding auch schon
fertig unsere füllung ist ja eigentlich
schon fertig aber ich gebe das immer
noch ganz gerne durch ein sieb damit ich
sicherstellen kann dass auch keine
klümpchen vorhanden sind
wem das nicht so richtig ist der kann
den schritt auch gerne aus lassen und
sofort weitermachen damit auf dem
pudding keine haut entsteht gebe ich da
auch wenn wir ihm gleich und
weiterverarbeiten trotzdem
frischhaltefolie drauf und dann geht es
schon weiter mit unserem hefeteig den
teig schneide ich einmal in der mitte
durch und mache mit der einen hälfte des
teigs weiter der wird nur noch ganz kurz
zu recht geknetet und dann rollen wir
ihn rund aus
[Musik]
mein helferkreis hat jetzt einen
durchmesser von ca 45 cm und ich
schneide ihn jetzt sind acht gleichmäßig
große stücke anschließend gebe ich auf
jedes stück ein esslöffel von dem
putting drauf und rolle ihn von der
breiten seite hin zur mitte ein
an den seiten seht ihr etwas von der
pudding füllung da braucht euch keine
sorgen machen es wird nichts
austretenden unser pudding ist ziemlich
fest falls sie allerdings einen fertig
pudding verwendet dann macht es so wie
hier im video gezeigt verschießt die
seiten lieber mal denn ich kann nicht
garantieren ob da nicht etwas auftritt
beim backen
sobald dann alle familie hörnchen fertig
aufgeräumt sind können sie auch schon
aufs backblech und werden mit einem
verkohlten gestrichen damit sie nach dem
backen auch schön braun aussehen
nach der backzeit geht es mit den noch
warmen hörnchen weiter und wir nehmen
uns etwas geschmolzene butter und zucker
zur hand
[Musik]
die vanille hörnchen werden dann von
außen mit der flüssigen butter
bestrichen und anschließend im zucker
gewälzt
[Musik]
diese schritte wiederholt ihr dann so
lange bis alle hörnchen fertig sind und
auch die zweite hälfte aus hefeteig
fertig gebacken ist aus den gegebenen
zutaten erhaltet ihr übrigens 16 große
leckere vanille hörnchen
[Musik]
falls jetzt auch lust habt auch total
fluffige und weiche vanille hörnchen
dann schaut man in die infobox da habe
ich für euch alle genauen mengenangaben
aufgeschrieben und ich freue mich wenn
ihr mich bei nach gemachten fotos auf
instagram mit dem hashtag kitchen
markiert falls ihr jetzt noch mehr
hörnchen von mir sehen möchtet dann
klickt auf jeden fall links auf eines
der beiden videos einmal habe ich für
euch die süße variante mit müssen und
einmal die orientalische herzhafte
variante und außerdem freue ich mich
wenn wir beim nächsten mal auch wieder
einschaltet
[Musik]